this is it
our last plenary session in Strasbourg
the european elections are coming
on June 6 we go to the polls
change is in the air
our parents and grandparents once signed for 1
common market
but secretly got 1
predominant political union
with flags
national anthems
common debts and now even towards 1
army while the voter never asked for it
or voted in favor
it is therefore not surprising that in the Netherlands
the european elections
traditionally know the lowest turnout
one wonders meanwhile
what sense does it actually make
but history teaches us one thing
political collaborations
like the European Union don't survive like the star
keeps moving in the same direction
they need to change
adapt
or die out
the time has now come in Europe
the flow of power from the Member States to Brussels
should be reversed
we must let power and resources flow back
back from Brussels to the member states and more
back to the Dutch